لا تؤثر تلك السياسه على قرارات شراءنا
لمنتجا او لخدمه ما بل تضع تفاصيل حياتنا
تحت مجهر اشخاصا وموجهه غير معروفات تؤثر
على توجهاتنا السياسيه والاجتماعيه دعونا
ان السكر ما حدث قبل ايام حيث قامت شركه
تويتر بتصريح نصف عاملها ولحقتها فيسبوك
بتسريحه 12 الف من الموظفيها حين هاجر
الديمقراطيون انتقادات لاذعه بشان قرار
ماسك واتهموه بانه يعرض قدره منصه على
تامين البيانات الشخصيه للمستخدميها للخطر
فيما وصفت خطته ذكر بيرج الخاصه لتصريح
الموظفين بانها استراتيجيه لاعاده الهيكله
هذا الامر طرح التساؤل هل تعني الخصوصيه
كثيرا لديمقراطيين ام يتوقف الامر على من
يقف خلف القرار
في رئيس مجلس النواب يقول لوصد جورنال ان
سعيا الون للحريه لحريه التعبير هو تهديد
مباشر للحزب الديمقراطي وحلفائه في وسائل
الاعلام القديمه الخوف اذا من ان يمنح
ماسك صوتا للمحافظين ويستخدم تاثيره على
الامريكيين لدعم الجمهوريين في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الاشهر القادمه
الطرفين على قضيه البيانات الشخصيه كلهم
من منصته بالطبعه ولتاثير على قرار اخر من
الامريكي في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
[موسيقى]